alright Jim Carrey is nearly here at
took me 25 years I've been a fan of Jim
Carrey since I first saw him in the club
to see is that a legendary career he's
got a new series on Showtime called KITT
Wow we don't usually get to plug
Showtime that shows what an icon you are
it's called kidding it starts Sunday Jim
Carrey everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody Wow good Wow let's check this
out
I went out today and bought me some
Nikes
[Applause]
that's right it's a salute to Colin
Kaepernick to Nike congratulations I'm
fantastic
[Applause]
it's great to see you in front of a
microphone oh man happy to be here
really I love you so much oh thank you
to this show forever
oh absolutely admire what you do well it
took me forever to get you here but I
know what would happen if I had to start
reading yeah waiting from your pretty
eye I would always wait for you I've
been a fan of yours I tell you since I
saw you the first time I ever saw you
you didn't act and you didn't even speak
you just did impressions with your face
that's right yeah that's right and I
said this guy yeah it started early when
I saw a Golden Pond when I was a kid I
was the theater and I was like I didn't
know I was doing it I saw myself in a
shop in a shop window and I went wow
that's his face it came from the inside
I by the way I have to tell you the
story but we auditioned the same night
at the Comedy Store for Mitzi oh come on
years ago years ago well you audition
certainly it was years ago Jim
that's the new school of thought all
time happens to okay well yeah I never
was you were enacted to cover that is my
Hilde and I suck right yeah I didn't
make it past so tight you got rich you
were regular and stuff I got up there
and the microphone fell apart in my
hands the first thing that happened you
know it's gonna be one of those nights
right even I ran past me it's C back to
Canada for two years I you know I've
noticed you know we're both around the
same age and you're a little younger but
as time goes by I noticed your mind
really moves the furniture I don't think
that was me I think you're transferring
them oh really
yeah I don't I never I never you're
thinking of Greg Kinnear no you're a
young Lamar I don't remember ever doing
one of the confident or I'm glad your
memories of my life are better than my
own beautiful you know I've seen you in
so many movies and one way I judge
actors is by like I look at a pardon ago
yeah he did great in that part could
anybody else do it and usually the
answer is yes sure
would you a lot of times Ace Ventura no
secret is making the wrong choices but
committing completely no I don't think
you have my favorite movie and I love
many of them is cable guy oh thank you
Mabel guy and Truman Show and I feel
like they should be on a film festival
together there's something about them
that is very prescient about the way the
world came to be absolutely you think
they are we are parentless we are
babysat by the television we're taught
how to think by the television that's
the dangerous time I think about what's
going on right now there's an there are
there are generations growing up right
now who are learning to lie the lying is
okay yeah that this kids a fake news
that you're supposed to hate half the
country well and if anything if anything
we've got to get back to a place where
we realize that a vote is not who you
are you know and and because you voted
looking you're not stupid you're not
different you're not worthless you know
I could break bread with anybody who
voted for Trump we could find some
common ground to love each other true
just stop doing stupid [ __ ] we expect
all right so get it together so let's
plug your show yes why this character
this hitting shot called kidding well
you know these sly like mr. Rogers yeah
guy who I think the show is really
interesting because first of all I get
to work with Michel Gondry again which
is a you know who did was a dream the
first time and a dream come true again
what movie was a China okay but yeah it
was a beautiful experience and it's
about a guy in it's about it's about
love being hit by lightning I mean this
this is about a gentleman whose heart is
so big and and his his approach is so
authentic
that it's undeniable when you come in
contact with them when he that sounds
like you I always thought well I was
thought of you as a seeker yeah you were
like you are always seeking something
right yeah you're not always happy no
I'm not always happy that's for sure
happy is the weather and sunny place
seeker let the flowers grow bro you know
because it's hard to find what you're
looking when it's deep yeah and and
basically I've learned how to and I am
as angry and caught up in this stuff as
anybody out rage it's like a carpet
bombing of outrage that's happening I
see it in your art absolutely you know I
first serious I didn't realize until I
saw you on Jerry Seinfeld's coffee show
yeah when you what he was at your studio
what a great artist you are and now I
see it all the time on social media
because it took me only show you a few
of these okay show they like this I love
this one of trunk
know that that's Ryan and Nunez are the
flying monkeys okay
perhaps I wasn't detailed enough to and
then Lincoln is then there's my Lincoln
curry didn't Lincoln symbolize I love
that because Trump is always the
president that actually you know had the
worst tribulations our country has ever
faced and brought us together now the
opposite is happening right now we have
a president who started out when the
country was together and it had a
wonderful leader and he is tearing us
limb from limb
well destroying every institution let's
let's talk about this Donald Trump you
know we don't want to let's bringing on
the panel he's a car salesman he's a
user Congress absolute and he's you know
he didn't he didn't make America great
again but he did turn back the odometer
[Applause]
where the backseat right right as I
watched this week what I kept thinking
was it all comes down to this case of
narcissistic personality disorder we've
all talked about it since you've been on
the public scene but we see it in real
time somebody really unravelling
spiraling toward madness so I know there
was a tape of him talking to Bob
Woodward right we heard that this week
at the end of it he gets a little
frustrated and he says well accurate is
that nobody's ever done a better job
than I'm doing as president he says how
can you what travel what demolition man
is clean a couple of its enclosure
couple of weeks ago he gave himself an
A+
you saw that even if you thought these
things you to say them out loud as often
as he does his trick right I mean he
kind of says these things that are so
outrageous over and over and over again
until eventually people think that there
must be something there right that even
if it's not you know even if he's not
worth 10 billion dollars he must be
worth like 1 billion dollars as opposed
to you know a few million or it was
supposed to being in debt a few million
right everybody ordered a hundred and it
was worth five right so that's the ratio
of truth to [ __ ] is 20 to 1 okay
it's 20 to 1 man when you have the
disorder you know like when his like I
was saying before his whole his personal
cabinet now has turned on him the person
with this disorder is never gonna go
maybe it's me buddy is saying you know
but you know the one not everybody sound
like Trump now everybody saying yeah
people are saying receiving end of one
of the Tantrums I met with him twice and
would you do well I told him no three
times it was face he took it well the
first time it was the second and third
times he didn't take it so we're in over
the health care issue and I tried to
explain him what I thought with problems
with a bill on Medicaid exchanges and
Planned Parenthood and in the time I the
second time I told him he said well are
you are you I told him I was opposed at
the bill and he said why so this is on a
Thursday I said well he said why I said
well be for the same reasons I told you
on Tuesday two days before and I said
went through the issues and he cut me
off and he said you're gonna destroy the
Republican Party
you know the tax reforms gonna go down
and it's just you're gonna destroy the
Republican Party because he couldn't
remember what you said on Tuesday no
because it because I want for the health
care bill he said way to take down my
wife my finally interrupted him after
about you know it seemed like gone
forever this was in the Cabinet Room
getting getting you know getting that
late into here
that's mr. president you tell him he did
this you said mr. president yeah as an
affirmation the health care bill didn't
pass and I said are you telling me if we
don't pass this health care bill in this
form we're not gonna be able to tax a
form because the baselines not low
enough
that's exactly right when you lose you
lose and off he went again and they're
in a whole room everybody says yes lean
yes if you lied to him and then he comes
back to me at the end you still hard no
I'm still no mr. president goes off of
me again and then I said well mr.
president and he's I'm talking to you I
don't hear any more from cloud ignore
Trump for a week no I had a girlfriend
one time long time ago and we're having
problems I went to therapy and and and
and the and the therapist said sounds
like your girlfriend's a little bit
borderline personality and she's you
know a narcissist and whatever and and I
said well maybe if I just you know find
a different way to intellectualize or
get used to what she's saying and I
could you know my comebacks would be
different and that I could just accept
the fact she's gonna be a dick every
once in a while whatever and she said
please do please please try for a week
to ignore and not react to these buttons
that are being port orders no I know we
don't sing there needs to be people
around them okay that's yeah okay so let
me ask about house we have the
Democratic consultant here of the last
successful election the Democrats seem
to be getting their groove back a little
bit and what ice when I mean by that is
that Alexander our caveat cobia Cortez I
Anna Presley Stacey Abrams kerryevelyn
Davis these are all women who won
primaries weren't supposed to and they
did it with unabashed liberal proposals
medicare-for-all
ending student debt a different approach
to the war on terror ending mass
incarceration it seems like if there is
a maybe a shining spot in this Trump
tragedy it's that it's made the
Democrats sort of rediscover who they
are and the voters is that what's going
on look I think those fundamental issues
health care a secure job security you
know and all of the things that are
being addressed whatever the whatever
form it takes you're hearing this kind
of a cross across the board those
candidates reflected their districts
well they reflect their their
constituencies well you know Connor lamb
and your state probably has a slightly
different slant on these things but
fundamentally the values I think are
very consistent and so you know the the
Republicans are running with the word
socialism they're trying to say and
scare people scare people immune ISM
Venezuela Trump says we're gonna be
living in Venezuela I grew up in Canada
okay we socialized medicine and I am I'm
here to tell you that this [ __ ] line
that you get on all of the political
shows from people is that it's a failure
the system is a failure in Canada it is
not a failure and can I never waited for
anything in my life
I chose my own doctors my mother never
paid for a prescription it was fantastic
and I just got back from Vancouver and I
keep hearing this like Canadians are so
nice
Canadians are so nice they can be nice
because they have health care
[Applause]
it doesn't say secret [ __ ] swim pal
right or you live in a box yeah there
are certain people in our society that
need to be taken care of there are there
are people without as many opportunities
that need to be helped toward those
opportunities there are people who are
sick but that's the don't have to lose
your home and as your mother got sick
and look I'm boy I've always said the
United States has been a quasi socialist
government for a hundred years for
crying out loud it's not a sauna plenty
of subsidies for oil companies and it
also Medicare and Social Security and
yes of course there's nothing more
socialistic than some of the Pentagon
programs that are just jobs programs the
Pentagon says we don't want these tanks
and they build them anyway if that's not
socialism I don't know what is
[Applause]